hello everyone and welcome to the
recapture of the saint louis rapido and
blitz my name is tatev abrahamian and
i'm going to take you to day two of
rapid
so we started today with two leaders
levon arunian and pantala hari krishnan
at the end of the day we're left with
one leader the world champion magnus
carlson the world champion had a
disappointing day one where he actually
got disconnected and he lost and then he
threw his third game against wesley so
but today he won all his games and now
he's in seoul lead
so let's dive into the games and see
what happened in day two
okay so let's start with our key
match-up of round four so we already had
a great uh
round we had levon aronian
with the black pieces facing the world
champion so this
uh games have always been great as levon
irwin was a long time number two and a
big rival of the world champion
but something went horribly wrong for
him star right from the beginning he
played the grunfeld and he got this
terrible position
right after d5
knight d7 so it's not
good to take because of knight c5 and d3
will hang
the world champion glass the bishop back
and uh white just has an amazing
position with this great center
and this uh destroyed uh pawn structure
next to the king and just everything is
in his favor so he won the game quite
easily so i will take you through the
rest of the game
so he just wins a pawn
uh doesn't treat queens because the king
the black king is bad so we don't trade
queens when our opponent has a pro king
centralizing the night centralizing the
rooks going after other weaknesses
distracting the queen and now this pawn
will also fall
and now the knight is not going to
survive for very long
there are no more checks there's no
funny business with rook g1
so queen b2 is played but forcing a
queen trade
up a uh aronian decides to resign
so our other leader pantala hari krishna
also lost his game he lost to
yanipongnichi
so let's take a look at that game let's
jump straight into game
move 25.
uh so this was kind of quite a complex
position
and uh in this position nippon she went
knight d3
and he got this pass pawn and actually
this pass pawn ended up winning the game
for him
so after this trade that happened uh
this pond is becoming a real problem for
white so attacking the knight
doubling protecting the pond and now uh
this is just a very healthy pass pawn
and we have a bishop versus a knight and
of course a knight in this kind of
position
is not going to fare well against the
bishop because the position is very open
and we have
pawns on both sides of the board so
let's see how the game
ended very good move
going to harass the rock away from d2
and just keep pushing the pawn
and now the pawn is all the way on d2
and the pass pawn that's on the second
round
rank is already a very strong pass pawn
and a
very difficult one to deal with
especially since it's defended by
the bishop so it's just going to be
untouchable
threatening to go roxy1 now we have a
threat of queen a1
so he decides to give the piece but the
game ends in just a couple more moves
uh so important win for uh yanipanichu
who actually
fracked hari krishna hare krishna
because he was a point behind so with
this win he got two points
so let's take a look at this game
between jeffrey zhang and alexander
krischuk which is a heartbreaking
loss for the young american player who
was defending for a long time in this
rook versus two minor pieces of the pawn
position but
this last move of queen king f3 walking
into a fork
really unfortunate just losing the game
um so the game between hikaru and
nakamura and uh alareza farouza was
quite wild
the opening was quite strange and
led to a very interesting pawn structure
uh if we look at it there are so many
pond weaknesses and so many pawn islands
so the mistake came in this position
that after 92
defending the pawn and transferring the
knight to f4 the young
grandmaster played knight c7 allowing
for knight g3
attacking the defender and now it's
impossible
to take and we're going to win some
material
so he decides to slide back with the
bishop
king d7 and now even though hikaru gave
up his uh bishop for the
knight he is going to pick up couple of
puns so these pawns are
very weak and if we look at this knight
this knight is actually
an amazing piece because it protects two
major targets
and now the spawns are just falling one
by one
so we're going to see an interesting end
game which um
i think it's a good one to look at
because we looked at rogue versus pawn
yesterday so today we have a different
version
so this pawn is running but
unfortunately it's not going to go too
far
i really like this before move chasing
the king away
taking on d5 and rook d4
and now the problem for this king is it
cannot get too close
so the king goes around and hikar is
okay with giving up his rook because he
has an avalanche of pawns
so you takes and
h7 is a threat and this kind of pawns
are unstoppable once two pawns for
example if you go back
once two pawns reach the sixth rank a
rook cannot handle them
because they're just going to queen for
example here
okay we're not going to blunder but
after something like this
h7 and the pawns will quit so
this was actually a very bloody round
with five decisive games so let's take a
look at our final decisive game between
the two americans west esso
and linear dominguez so let's jump to
move
27 this this game was also
pretty wild if we take a look at what's
going on wesley is attacking and lanier
after queen g3 lanier pushes his pawn so
a very dynamic position
and actually the way um lanier lost is a
bit counter intuitive with
another example of this yesterday when
he throws in a check
and um you know when you throw in a
check usually is to win time like the
five seconds on the clock
and actually it misplaces the bishop he
should have played
king g7 uh defending this pawn
but um after bishop c5
i will show you the difference king g7
there's a very annoying move e6
and with threatening queen e5 and the
bishop
so now actually the bishop is very
poorly placed
and something like this this king is
just not going to survive very long here
something like this we're already
getting made it
so just one move makes such a big big
difference in the position and this move
actually looks harmless it just looks
like you're winning
we're winning time on the clock so this
happens i think he realized that
something has gone wrong
so we went for this end game another
kink has to go to g8
so now pushing the pawn is impossible
picking up the rook and stopping the
pawn instead king h7 was played
but with checks with this nice geometry
he picks up
the rook again and is just too much
material
so uh let's move on to our next round so
let's move on to
round five so round five was a lot
quieter
it only had two decisive results so i
mentioned that
magnus carlsen was won all his game so
it's not hard to guess
which one was one of the decisive games
and the second decisive game was
actually by jeffrey zhang
the young american grandmaster who
played a phenomenal game played a
miniature to defeat
with the black pieces yanipondachi so
actually we can take a look at the whole
game because it's quite short
so with the black pieces jeffrey plays
the
ariohin alakan defense um he said in the
commentary that he was just looking for
a game
but what he got was much better
so let's just go through the opening to
our key moment
and here um this pawn grab is
quite greedy and the problem is this
king
and this development and now tactically
it is just not working out
should be five and now check
and the problem is um
so can get fund gets made it and this
would run into something like knight d4
and this rook is ours we don't even have
to take it right now
and uh the rook is ours and i want to
say so is this king because this king
actually doesn't really have any good
places to go to
and looks like uh it may not survive for
too long could capture this back we'll
just
at the very least can pick up a rook so
instead he goes bishop b5
jeffrey decides to give up his knight
so repeats once um he considered bishop
c4 he didn't seem
inconclusive but i really like the move
he plays here rook b6 which really
limits
the queen so the queen cannot reach the
king in any kind of position to protect
him
and simply takes back and it's actually
kind of a funny looking position because
uh
if the king hasn't moved we could have
castled
and okay it would be some kind of a
position and if you if someone gave you
this position
that you probably wouldn't think that
the king had moved right because it's
its initial place
but because the king has moved this is
just a struggle for
why there's not much to do plus queen d5
and takes and the position is quite
miserable there's too many threads
this is a thread this is a thread this
is a thread
and yanny palmer she just decided to
resign this game and just
and end the suffering here because
there's just not much to do
and now let's take a look at the game
between lanier dominguez and magnus
carlsen because that
was quite remarkable the world champion
spotted such a beautiful tactic
um that really broke the harmony in his
opponent's position
so let's go to um the key position
of the of the game so in this position
lanier dominguez plays queen e4 which
looks like a
normal move and then immediately the
engine bar
goes down which means that black is
winning and it's kind of mysterious
because
like why should black be winning here
it's because he has this beautiful shot
of rook b2
and rook b2 is impossible because e4 is
hanging
so the king has to take and now d3 and
now we see the power of this bishop
so the king goes back and the geometry
here
is just um really beautiful
iran tries to run away and then bishop
comes into play again
so lanier decides to resign here in view
of
take and here actually we have to be
careful
as black because bishop p1 runs into
trouble
there's this move f6 and now black is
the one who has to make a draw because
this gets made it
so black has to go back and
white can give a perpetual but of course
black doesn't have to do this
like simply can't take
i think this is the easiest one and just
go for this winning end game with
two extra pawns so after bishop h4
lanier resigned the game so this was two
in a row for the world champion
and next game he is uh playing with the
white pieces
he is playing against mantala hare
krishna so during the post game
interview
um after the three rounds he said the
rounds one and three were a gift
and round one i think he said that
because he just got such a great
position after 10 moves completely
dominating
and in this position in this game his
opponent simply blundered in one move
which is always such a painful way to
lose a game when you're playing while
you're playing fine and then one will
just cost you the game
so if in this position um higher
christian goes knight c5 which is
um you know attacking the two bishops so
it looks like maybe
uh we're forcing a trait to go
into opposite color bishop position but
unfortunately there is rook f1 and the
problem is the queen cannot go anywhere
to defend the knight because
of back rank issues
so now white has sorry black has the
decision of
either giving up a knight or giving up a
queen for the two miners
for a rook and a minor so he decides to
do that
but unfortunately the position does not
offer enough counter play
and i cannot take back because of uh
another pin like so many nice tactics
we'll see why the world champion is just
amazing
and um hari krishna decides to just
resign
also you don't have a move we don't have
really have a good move
with the kink and something like h4 is
going to be in the air trapping this
knight at some point
so another smooth win by the world
champion who is now leading the
tournament
so let's take a look at our other
decisive games the one between hikaru
nakamura and yanni bomnichi
and this game was completely wild i
cannot really do it justice in this kind
of video because
it was just so complicated hikaru gave
up three pawns
he didn't get much for it because his
count his um
follow-up was a little on inaccurate
then it was up and down
there was um queen versus to rook
position
so there's just a lot happen in this
game that will take
probably hours to really analyze
thoroughly so let me just show you what
happened
because we reached the position on move
51
and the engine here was already saying
that this position
is close to a draw because
there is a move queen e7 going after
this pawn and
it's actually very uncomfortable to
defend this pawn
because now the queen is going to start
checking um and there's never any kind
of blocking of checks because the rook
is hanging
instead he carried take the pawn on f5
and actually it's kind of funny because
uh by taking his pawn it looks like it's
ecoli getting close to equalizing the
material
but actually he's making his king weaker
because the f5 pawn
was preventing any kind of two rook
checkmates
so rook g3 now the king is cut off so
there's
all kinds of meeting nets coming up
now putting the king in a box
and now this check is coming
to check and um
now we're getting checkmated
so this didn't happen after rook f5 he
resigned but
i thought it was very instructive how
taking the wrong pawn actually hurts
your position because
the white king was hiding behind that
pawn the white king could actually stay
on the f file when the pawn was there
because there was no
checks on the f file and our
final game final decisive game um it's
also a bit of a heartbreaker
it's a game between uh lanier dominguez
and alireza ferrugia
so alareza actually ran out of time
because we had this final position
that had a result and we had this
yesterday when we're looking and
wondering
why is there a result what's going on
there's no way uh
someone resigns in a wild position this
doesn't happen
and turns out he ran out of time which
is really unfortunate this was also a
wild game he was doing really well
so he already gave up his advantage but
something like queen c6
something like this would be a
repetition so maybe he was looking for
something more he was looking for a win
in a position didn't realize his long
time and run out of time
again like wandering in one move
disconnection like flagging like this
all of them are very disappointing way
of losing the game
but uh this is also flagging is
something that can happen
over the board too so it's not just
something that happens online
so it was a tough day for the young
player he lost two games
but tomorrow is another day tomorrow is
actually going to be
the final day of the rapid and in the
rapids
um each win is worth two points and a
dry is one point and loss is zero which
is twice as much than it is in blitz
so if magnus carlsen kind of runs away
with it it's going to make it difficult
for anyone to catch up to him so
tomorrow i think it's a big round
because
the players who are chasing him will
need to um if they cannot
um catch up to him maybe keep the gap at
one point which is where it is right now
so i think there's a lot of pressure on
his opponents to try to keep up with
magnus and he
he has another day where he wins three
out of three and uh that might be very
difficult to do
so make sure you're tuning in tomorrow
to san luis chess club youtube channel
or to usgsjumps.com
1pm central see you there and thank you
for checking out this video